A data science,
ai,
machine learning,
or these are all things that are in the
middle year right now.
I think if they fundamentally point at
the same idea,
the same concept around my call it
machine intelligence,
where it's about how do you use
computers and the vast amount of data
that's out there,
that kind of big data and then leverage
that to make more intelligent decisions
as an organization.
Um,
as a government,
as a nonprofit,
this really comes from a few major
secular trends that are happening.
One is the plummeting cost of
computation,
uh,
and the plumbing costs of storage.
So now we have the capacity to store
that data relatively cheaply and three
other process that data relatively
cheaply.
And then the other major trend is that
everyone's walking around with
smartphones.
Everyone's interacting with the Internet
for a large part portion of the day.
And so we're able to capture huge parts
of the human experience and digitize
that information and store it in the
cloud.
So when we have all these connected
devices that are measuring us,
we can actually understand a lot about
human behavior.
And that's actually really,
really fascinating.
Um,
and we're from that we're able to create
products,
services,
uh,
that are so much more rich and so much
more personalized than we've been able
to do before.
And so if you think about maybe even the
simplest example might be something like
a Netflix,
right?
With recommendation engine that's able
to serve up content in a very targeted
way.
So that's they give you,
they show you out of there,
you know,
library of probably millions of possible
videos where you watch the five to 10
that you're most likely to want to
watch.
And they can do this from what's called
a lookalike analysis where they will
look at what other people who have
watched a similar set of videos as you
have,
how have they've rated those videos,
how much they've liked those videos,
and then see what other videos those
people of light that you haven't yet
watched.
And that's probably a good candidate for
a video that you should wash,
right?
So that kind of look alike analysis.
Or if you're a data scientist,
you'd probably call that a
recommendation engine.
That's actually a very powerful
technique,
uh,
and it's sort of very fundamental to a
business that has tens of millions of
videos and they know you're only going
to watch one tonight,
right?
How do you pick out that one good video?
So that's not just a huge search problem
is for a consumer,
but it's actually a pleasurable
experience for them and that's,
you know,
has implications beyond Netflix,
right?
If you think about a company like Amazon
that's incredibly important for them,
uh,
they have billions of items on their
store.
You need to be able to figure out what
to buy and so they can tell you the
right item.
They can maybe get you to buy something
that you otherwise would have purchased
and that's know has a direct impact on
their bottom line.
And it also makes consumers happier,
right?
It helps you reduce the amount of time
you spend searching for products and
services.
So I think these kind of data enabled
services where companies can give you
what you want when you want it,
that's becoming increasingly powerful
within the kind of consumer markets and
it's becoming increasingly the standard.
So I think what we've seen is that for a
lot of legacy enterprises,
um,
that are not digital first,
that haven't been able to embrace data
and data science,
there's a,
almost a kind of an adversarial
relationship between the consumer and
that product or service where you're
saying as a consumer,
hey,
I have this great experience when I'm
interacting with facebook or google or
Netflix,
they seem to give me what I want.
Why can't you give me what I want?
And when you experienced that,
right,
there's a lot of fear on the part of
those companies,
the legacy companies that their ability
to sort of maintain that market is going
to rapidly evaporates and it's going to
be deteriorate rates at a really quick
rate if any of these sort of digital
companies,
uh,
enter that market because they
understand how to leverage data.
They understand how to use that,
uh,
the information they have or consumers
to give consumers a fundamentally better
product.
There's obviously a lot in the news
about Cambridge Analytica,
um,
facebook and how we societaly deal with
data and how we are,
how we should deal with data.
Should there be regulation?
Should we have more privacy protections?
Um,
and I think these are really interesting
and valid questions.
Uh,
we,
we as a society should ask,
right?
And it seems that's where entering a
period where there's certainly within
Europe with the passenger Gdpr,
there is increasing reluctance to just
say a facebook,
Google,
you can have free reign over all of our
data in an unchecked way.
And I think we'll see what happens as we
move forward,
uh,
with a regulation and this kind of
consumer protections.